bonsoir thomas quelle est exactement la
situation sanitaire aux états unis parce
que c'est vrai que ici en france on en
parle moins en ce moment bonsoir
stéphanie alors ici il ya une inquiétude
également autour de ce fameux variant
delta il serait responsable aujourd'hui
d'une contamination sur 5 sur l'ensemble
du territoire mais il ya assez peu de
doute sur le fait que ce variant finira
par être majoritaires ici aux etats unis
les autorités sanitaires estiment
qu'elles ont entre un et deux mois de
retard sur la situation britannique il
surveille donc très attentivement ce
qu'il se passe au royaume uni le prévoit
notamment les modèles pourrait bien
suivre la situation en britannique pour
revoir ce qui pourrait être évitée ici
aux etats unis
l'autre inquiétude elle concerne la
couverture vaccinale sur l'ensemble du
territoire aujourd'hui il ya 46 % de la
population américaine qui est totalement
vacciner et ce chiffre n'est pas
suffisant selon les autorités sanitaires
là encore pour complètement mettre un
terme à cette pandémie de kobe 19 et
puis surtout il y à de très fortes
disparités entre les états on sait que
sur les côtes est et ouest des états
unis
globalement la population est très
largement vacciner mais en revanche dans
les étapes plus ruraux ou dans les états
du sud du pays
on arrive à des chiffres bien inférieurs
je prends l'exemple de l'arkansas et en
arkansas
seuls 34% de la population est à ce jour
vacciner on sait que l'objectif de joe
biden ne sera donc pas tenus le
président américain avait fixé la date
du 4 juillet dimanche prochain jour de
la fête nationale américaine
avec un objectif 70 % de la population
américaine qui aurait reçu au moins une
dose de vaccin on n'arrivera pas à cet
objectif qui sera atteint qui sera
atteint probablement quelques semaines
plus tard alors malgré tout joe biden
continue d'encourager les américains à
se faire vacciner il était en caroline
du nord il ya quelques jours justement
pour délivrer ce message il dit vouloir
un été sans qu'ovide un été festif
écoutez le président des états unis joe
biden donc en caroline du nord
ce variant delta est plus facilement
transmissible
potentiellement plus mortelle est
particulièrement dangereux pour les
jeunes les jeunes dr anthony fauci dit
que c'est la plus grande menace pour
notre combat contre le coc vie de 19
la bonne nouvelle c'est que nous avons
une solution
la science est sans appel la meilleure
façon de se protéger contre le virus et
ses variantes et de se faire vacciner
complètement l'émergence de ce variant
delta et l'inquiétude qu'ils suscitent
conduit en tout cas certaines autorités
locales à prendre des mesures a imposé
de nouvelles restrictions il ya par
exemple le comté de los angeles qui
recommande désormais très vivement à ses
habitants de porter le masque en
intérieur et compris les américains qui
ont été vaccinés on sait pourtant qu'il
ya quelques semaines maintenant le port
du masque n'est plus obligatoire ici en
intérieur et bien voilà des autorités
locales qui commence à reprendre des
mesures il ya donc une très forte
inquiétude
autre conséquence de ces indicateurs
sanitaires qui ne sont pas bons le plus
en plus maintenant de politiques
encouragent les plus jeunes à se faire
vacciner notamment en vue de la rentrée
des classes qui dans certains états aura
lieu à dès le mois d'août prochain il
n'y a pas encore de décision sur le fait
que le port du masque soit rendue
obligatoire dans les salles de classe
c'est un débat qui a lieu en ce moment
et il sera tranché très localement vous
savez ici que les décisions sont prises
à l'échelle d'un état parfois même d'un
comté autre conséquence de toutes ces
inquiétudes et bien c'est la réouverture
des frontières qui tarde
on sait que les américains ont le droit
eux de se rendre en europe pour voyager
mais il n'y a pas de réciprocité les
européens ont toujours interdiction
d'entrer sur le territoire américain
sans motif impérieux
certains avaient espéré que le voyage de
joe biden et de son secrétaire d'état
anthony blinken en europe puisse
conduire à des annonces en ce sens il
n'en a rien été et même les frontières
terrestres des états unis que ce soit
avec le canada ou avec le mexique
resteront fermés au moins jusqu'au 21
juillet prochain
il y avait un certain nombre d'acteurs
économiques qui presse le gouvernement a
levé ses restrictions parce qu'on sait
que cette fermeture de frontières a un
impact considérable pour un certain
nombre d'acteurs économiques de la
région
il ya aussi un aspect politique
évidemment dans cette crise sanitaire
vous avez des médias américains qui font
un parallèle en ce moment entre eux à
l'épée les états où la vaccination est
faible avec les états qui ont le plus
voté pour donald trump il met en
parallèle le nombre de personnes non
vaccinées dans certains a compté dans
des états ruraux et le nombre de
personnes qui ont voté pour donald trump
lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle comme pour a expliqué que
peut-être parmi les plus réfractaires se
trouverait finalement des électeurs de
l'ancien président pourtant on sait
donald trump lui est plutôt pro
vaccination il avait même acheté
beaucoup de doses à l'époque au début de
la pandémie même si ces derniers jours
il faut dire qu'il a montré quelques
réserves notamment sur la vaccination
des plus jeunes il ya donc comme dans
d'autres pays une défiance vis-à-vis de
la parole officielle ici aux etats unis
un certain nombre de réfractaires qui ne
veulent toujours pas se faire vacciner
et une personne incarne justement cette
défiance de la parole officielle c'est
le docteur anthony fauci le conseiller
santé de la maison blanche qui est la
cible de critiques très vives depuis
plusieurs semaines maintenant
depuis que des mails ont été publiées
dans des médias américains et que
certains estiment qu'ils ne tient un
discours complètement différent en
public qu'en privé voilà donc ce qui
pousse a alimenté la défiance de
certains américains donc pour la
vaccination est ce qui conduit les
autorités ici aux etats-unis à avoir une
très forte inquiétude joe biden avait
dit vouloir faire de la lutte contre la
pandémie
la priorité de son mandat force est de
constater qu'il reste encore du travail
à faire pour le président américain
merci à thomas bonnin en direct de
washington